AI for a good lab really helped open my
eyes about what's happening in the AI
field this year I actually had way more
uh women's here we creating a role model
for our students it's just I think
really uh inspiring to think about all
the ways that we can actually use AI for
social
[Music]
good I had the pleasure of being able to
judge but it was very hard task to judge
I saw merits in every single one of the
projects they understand all the issues
and how you Source data how you trade
data how you train models um and then
they're just really like thinking about
it and also trying to deliver an
impactful product the environment in
which I found myself at AI for good at
MAA was very collaborative I could learn
a lot from my peers and I found people
who were very available to explain to me
things I didn't understand to offer me
their help this way I could really learn
a lot from every experience we had it
teaches you to have that sense of
responsibility and ownership um of your
intellectualism and also the impact that
you have on society Mila is a very
welcoming inclusive space and it's
really just like a big community so it
really makes me feel comfortable
learning because um you know there's a
really good support system everywhere
you go in the
place